One of the best things about being a scientist is you get to spend your day solving puzzles.
You have this interesting scientific question...
...and you spend years sometimes trying to get the answer.
And the prize when you solve the puzzle is you get a new puzzle.
Each new discovery branches out into all these new and interesting ideas.
My name is Steve Buratowski, I'm a professor at Harvard Medical School...
...and my lab works on the punctuation of the genome.
If you look at your DNA sequence, it's just this long string of letters.
It's like a book that has no spaces between the words, no punctuation, no title page.
It turns out your genome does have all that...
...and we're trying to figure out how that works.
So, it turns out that a lot of diseases, things like cancer, developmental defects...
...are caused by problems in either writing or reading this punctuation...
...and so by figuring out the basic mechanisms,...
...we're gonna contribute to developing therapeutics for patients.